the bigger news coming out of baseball
beyond the fact that baseball is back as
it relates to the covet 19 situation
and the protocols that baseball is using
and the protocols football will be using
outfitter juan soto of the washington
nationals fell into a doughnut hole
that the nfl is very concerned about
that lag between when you
give a test and when the test result
comes back
and what you do in the interim and as it
turned out for soto he was tested on a
tuesday
played in an exhibition game against the
orioles on tuesday night
worked out at nationals park on
wednesday and then found out on thursday
morning
that that test from tuesday was positive
so obviously he didn't play last night
he wasn't in the stadium last night but
the question becomes
who may he have infected against the
orioles on tuesday
who may he have infected in the
clubhouse or wherever on wednesday
and that's what the nfl is dealing with
shireen until there is
point of care testing that can give a
result within
15 minutes half hour 45 minutes or a
full hour
where you don't have to send it away and
wait for 24 hours
in that 24 hours between collection of
sample
and communication of result you can have
somebody
who ultimately was positive when the
test was
was taken who has been on a practice
field
around teammates or worst case scenario
in a game against opponents for three
hours
out there sweating and breathing and
coughing and bleeding
and that that's the ultimate chemistry
experiment for the nfl that's the
you know the players of the guinea pigs
to see whether or not there will be
transmission
in that kind of a setting because juan
soto's example proves to us
that that possibility is real that
there's going to be a guy who slips
through the cracks when the time lag is
24 hours
from when the test is is harvested to
when the test is finalized
and look football's way worse than
baseball baseball doesn't have
contact when you're out in the outfield
i mean you're more than
six feet away from the the other
outfielder when you're in field
you're more than six feet away so they
do have the social distancing
in baseball for the most part aside from
when they're in the dugout and they wear
the mask when when they're in the dugout
some of them wear out them out in the
field but football you're just not going
to have that and some players we already
know are resistant to wearing
these masks so they're going to be
spitting all over each other and
sweating all over each other and
bleeding all over each other and
we did see an example in the xfl right
before it closed of a player test and
positive and we don't know how that
spread
because it shut down right after that
but it very easily could spread and very
quickly could spread
in the nfl we see why the nfl wants the
nflpa
wants daily testing there's no question
about that that's what they need but
they've got to turn these things around
these tests around
very quickly to get the results and not
have
happen what juan soto had happened where
you are
amongst your teammates and you have
tesla you do have it and you don't know
you have it at the time
yeah i had somebody connected to the
union try to push back on me a little
bit last night when i raised this point
arguing that there would be a test on
friday you go into a bubble
after that in advance of a sunday game
so if it comes back saturday that you're
positive you're going to be out
but it's unlikely that you're going to
have a situation where you test
on saturday and you get the positive on
sunday or i
i look i don't i i look back at the text
again i didn't follow it when i got it i
don't follow it now the reality is
there's always going to be a lag there's
always going to be a possibility
that you develop the positive
one day after you test negative right if
you're tested every day
negative negative negative positive
that's how it works the positive just
happens
if in that 24 hours between generation
of the sample that becomes positive and
finding out it was positive
you play in a game you're going to
potentially infect
other people people from other teams
teammates i mean that's the one moment
where everyone gets thrown into a
blender they can do everything they can
all week long
to keep guys six feet apart and to wear
masks and to be careful and
and even if they're doing eleven on
eleven drills there are ways that they
can
you know either not huddle or use the
wider line splits as they do walk
throughs
there are all sorts of precautions you
can take and they will but when it's
time to play a game
if one guy's out there who's positive
you're right shireen it's not like
baseball
where everyone is spread out they're all
pressed together
and there is a way that you are going to
potentially have a guy
who tested saturday it came back
negative gives a test sunday before the
game
it comes back positive after the fact
then you have to do all the contact
tracing and all the enhanced testing and
you have to watch and wait and see
if you're going to have an outbreak
that's the concern that football has
and that's what they need to be taking
seriously until they have point of care
testing
the great thing for baseball and for the
nfl looking forward is that baseball
conducted in their last round of tests
that they announced conducted over ten
thousand tests they had five
positive tests less than one percent but
if it's just
one player in football and he's around
all those other players and doesn't know
he's positive he's asymptomatic
then they're gonna have a problem
because we know how quickly it spreads
so that
that five positive test on the one week
could turn
into 25 30 40 positive tests who knows
how many
uh the next time they test and so that's
the danger you face you also
face the danger of a whole group of
players say all the quarterbacks which
you know bruce aaron said he may
quarantine a quarterback but what if
all your quarterbacks test positive the
friday before a game what are you going
to do
for a quarterback so there are so many
hurdles left
even if nfl and nfl pa agree on what
they need to agree on there are tons of
hurdles left for this season
to transpire from start to finish
the biggest leap of faith the biggest
role of the dice that the nfl is taking
here is that
and they believe this to be true that
transmission
in an open-air stadium or under a very
high
dome that has a ventilation system that
was designed
to counter an aerosol attack by
terrorists and all of the domes have
that level of technology
that in that setting the transmission
rates will be ridiculously
low that the transmission happens most
frequently in confined
spaces now we'll find out whether or not
that's true
but they're pinning the hopes for the
2020 season
on that because it's inevitable that one
of these guys week one when they're
playing all those games
one of those guys will have given a test
that morning after previously testing
negative
we'll test that morning and find out the
next day that he was positive and he
would have played in the game
and that is going to be an issue that
the nfl needs to be ready to deal with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports